I'm here with Alibaba chairman and
co-founder Jack Ma the man himself
congratulations first of all you
believed that
Alibaba could be big even when the
internet was in its earliest and
roughest form what do you have to say
that to the people who thought you were
crazy yeah I think you know as we give
the souvenir today that everybody should
have a dream what if that dream comes
true
so I believe the 15 years ago that
Internet is gonna change China is going
to improve the world whether you believe
or not whether we will succeed or not
but somebody will succeed so if you
don't work hard if you don't keep on
working every day nobody has a chance so
we are we I never know that we will be
here today so what do you do with all
this new capital would you buy Yahoo
well I don't know whether this cell but
would you consider it no I think the
very important thing is that we want to
build up a company not the buying
company we want to make sure that our
ecosystem helps the small guys anything
that can help small business growth we
will consider have you spoken with
Marissa Mayer what are you spoken about
I we talked about a couple of months ago
and yesterday she send a nice email to
me congratulation anything yeah what are
the biggest challenges of being a global
company and dealing with the Chinese
government well being a global company
dealing with any government is difficult
so as it's a great opportunity if you
deal with the government well and
communicate with them listen to their
problem solve their problems tell them
they're your problems that's opportunity
for communication that's what we
survived in past 15 years always try to
say in love with the government but
don't marry with them I mean this is
this our philosophy making sure that you
solve the problem they want to solve
u.s. expansion you've said it's very
important what's the timeline when will
we see you expand significantly in the
United States we already started helping
a lot of small business in the u.s. in
California and Washington State we sell
American cherries and we're sally alaska
seafood and we want to sell more things
we are coming here now to compete we're
coming here to
helped a lot of small business which I
think a lot of things need to be done
it's not of a competition
someone suggested a joint venture with
Amazon would that ever happened well
really I heard about it from you I have
never got bad 5 I would be interested in
talking as always anything
anybody that involving helping small
business we will feel excited you've got
a lot of US companies trying to expand
in China a lot of US companies have
failed in China yet CEOs tech leaders
going there to try to get a leg up what
kind of mistakes are they making I think
you know a vicious and intrapreneurs
there every market if it is a market
economy you have to making sure you have
the entrepreneurs that not only the
professional managers my my view is that
try to make your customer happy instead
of make your boss happy and making sure
send people there understand market have
patience and having have the time to do
that and what we want to do is that we
want to help a lot of small guys because
big guys are ready in China small guys
they need a help like us and we this is
what we're excited about Alibaba is it
successful in part because it's so
diverse and so sprawling I'm curious
what kinds of business ideas have you
said no to I'm saying no to a lot of
ideas because as a CEO I have to see
no.2 opportunities because if I say yes
I probably get a 5,000 opportunities
every day but where are the years or no
everything based on the meshing that
were helping is doing business easier if
it's on that we'll consider if our
somebody come here saying can you will
you don't have this issue you will make
a lot of money I'm not interested you
step down as CEO a couple of years ago
you're now executive chairman are you
really the CEO still no I'm the chairman
I focus my time on training developing
people I focus my time on government
relationship with all the nations that
help you small business I focus in my
time of global expansion that's all
stretch is thinking I don't do any you
know it's got an operation work you
surprised us all the time Jack what's
your next surprise well it's coming
how you gonna celebrate with your
co-founders well we had a big dinner
last night
and everybody cried and we said well you
know 15 years we never know that we
could have through who are the people
who should have thankful we say we thank
the customers we thank the young that
the people's not us so that's why we put
the young people there with the
customers because we believe after 15
years the purpose of working so hard is
that we want to make these people
successful because when they successful
our success is a result you love to sing
a karaoke party yeah we do I know but I
don't have time but I would try to
squeeze him all the time when I'm
getting old
that's it yeah sometime I was saying
again all right I love to hear you jack
Amal congratulations thank you so much